type 2 diabetes slowly arms a condition
that affects the way your body
metabolizes sugar it causes the body to
resist insulin or produce insufficient
amounts of insulin the hormone
responsible for maintaining blood
glucose homeostasis of the pancreas
secretes insulin into the bloodstream
when blood glucose levels rise insulin
travels to the body cells and triggers
them to increase chemicals updates by
attaching yourself to this receptor and
activating sucrose transporters which
allows some folks to pass through the
cell membrane when the body does not
produce insulin or if the cells are
resistant to insulin we supposed to not
be converted to energy myself and slugs
equals levels take longer to return to
homeostasis common symptoms include
excessive thirst frequent urination
expensive hunger fatigue
Laurie vision and slow hearing of custom
later symptoms include blindness and
nerve damage metformin a biguanide is
the most common medication to treat Type
2 diabetes
it increases peripheral insulin
sensitivity and decreases losses on
activity and intestinal absorption of
glucose which reduces the amount
available to enter the bloodstream that
tub cedilla peptidase-4 inhibitors are
another treatment option
dpp-4 is a membrane-bound protein that
is able to inactivate incretins Formosa
regulate insulin glucagon by clipping
off two amino acids from their ends when
dpp-4 inhibitors are attached they block
the active site we saw CTP for from
breaking down in [ __ ] such as
glucagon-like peptide once in doing so
the naturally occurring glp-1 hormone
can circulate in the body for longer
which stimulates insulin production and
inhibits Musa Khan productions move on
an insulin are antagonistic hormones
that work in upholding ways to regulate
blood glucose levels so by inhibiting
Blizzcon it prevents the liver from
breaking down glycogen into glucose
thanks for listening
we hope you enjoyed